hey this is presh talwalkar
in the following star-shaped figure
what is the measure of angle a in
degrees
this problem appeared on a test given to
8th grade students in 1999
approximately 75 percent of students did
not mark the correct answer
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for the
solution
one way to solve this problem is by
using several geometric principles
one principle is that a straight line
measures 180 degrees
we can look at the angle next to 100
degrees
and calculate that it must be 180 minus
100 or 80 degrees
similarly the angle next to 110 degrees
must equal 180 minus 110 and therefore
that angle is equal to 70 degrees
we now use the principle that the angles
in a triangle sum up to 180 degrees
in the triangle with 40 degrees and 70
degrees the final angle will be equal to
180 minus 40 minus 70.
so the final angle in this triangle is
70 degrees
we then use the principle that vertical
angles have equal measure
so the angle above 70 degrees is equal
to 70 degrees
and finally we again use the principle
that the three angles in a triangle sum
to 180 degrees this means angle a is
equal to 180 minus 80 minus 70
and therefore angle a is equal to 30
degrees
so that's our answer 30 degrees
there is in fact a quicker way to solve
this problem
you only need to use one principle which
is that the angles in a triangle sum up
to 180 degrees
the trick
is to look at the correct triangles
first we'll consider the triangle that
involves the 40 degree angle and the 100
degree angle
we know that all three angles add up to
180 degrees
the third angle therefore will be 180
minus 100 minus 40.
this angle is equal to 40 degrees
we now consider another triangle which
involves angle a
the other angles are 110 and 40 degrees
therefore angle a will equal 180 minus
110 minus 40.
so we directly get that angle a equals
30 degrees and we get to our answer much
quicker
did you figure out this problem
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on facebook google plus and
patreon you can catch me on social media
at preshtalwalker and if you like this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description